Que celle ou celui qui n'a jamais
fait un test de QI sur Internet
l'écrive dans les commentaires.
On a tous fait ça.
Nous sommes tous déjà, presque tous,
intéressés à notre QI. Pour se
comparer aux autres principalement,
on va pas se mentir.
Mais qu'est ce que réellement le QI ?
Est-ce que c'est fiable, d'ailleurs ?
Est ce qu'il existe des super QI ?
De plus de 200 ? Est-ce qu'on
peut booster son QI d'ailleurs ?
Est-ce qu'on peut booster son QI d'abord ?
Eh bien oui.
Et tu sais quoi?
Il y a même des bébés de 2 ans
qui ont déjà des QI de plus de 150.
Ah ? De 2 ans ?
De 2 ans.
Tu sais ce que ça m'inspire? Non !
Un Loïc générique, ça monsieur.
Il n'existe pas de date précise
sur le moment où l'être humain a voulu
commencer à mesurer son intelligence.
Mais au 19ème siècle,
le neurologue allemand Franz Joseph Gall,
rien à voir avec France Gall
C'est drôle quand même
Franz Gall, il s'appelait.
Non ?
Franz Joseph Gall travaille sur la cranioscopie,
qu'on appellera
plus tard la phrénologie.
D'après lui, le crâne est divisé en 26 zones
qui déterminent notre
intelligence suivant leur forme.
Par exemple, si vous avez une proéminence
à un endroit, c'est à dire une bosse,
cela veut dire que vous avez
la prédisposition qui est
associée à cette zone.
La bosse des maths,
ça vient de là effectivement.
Il y aurait aussi la bosse
de l'amour conjugal, celle
de l'appétit et même celle du meurtre.
Genre, si on voyait quelqu'un avec une bosse
à cet endroit là, on se dirait c'est
un meurtrier, il faut l'enfermer.
Pour Franz Joseph Gall, l'intelligence se
situerait dans 8 de ces 26 zones.
En 1905, le psychologue français
Alfred Binet et le psychiatre Théodore
Simon laissent de côté la phrénologie.
Pourquoi ?
Parce que ce n'est pas du tout une science.
C'est une pseudo science qui ne repose
sur rien de concret et de scientifique.
Ils font donc leurs propres recherches
et publient la première version de
l'échelle du développement intellectuel.
Ils appellent ça le test Binet-Simon.
Très pratique parce que c'est leur nom
et le résultat indique
l'âge mental du candidat.
Sept ans plus tard,
William Stern, un psychologue allemand,
reprend les travaux de Binet
et cherche des cas...des cabinets.
C'est bien non ?
Merci
Il reprend les travaux de Binet
et en sort le concept de quotient intellectuel
qu'on appellera plus tard le QI.
C'est très simple.
Vous prenez votre résultat au test Binet-Simon,
vous le divisez par votre âge réel,
vous le multipliez par 100
et tadam! Vous avez votre QI.
C'est d'ailleurs le fait qu'il faille
diviser qui fait qu'on parle
de quotient intellectuel.
Enfin, en 1939 David Wechsler
créé le QI standardisé.
La référence n'est plus alors l'âge
de la personne, mais le résultat obtenu
par rapport à la population en général.
Et son travail donnera naissance
aux examens de QI qu'on
utilise encore aujourd'hui.
Alors, la question qu'on se pose,
c'est qui qui a le plus gros cerveau ?
Le plus gros QI ?
La personne vivante la plus intelligente sur la planète
serait à ce jour
Terence Tao, un Australien d'origine chinoise
de 45 ans dont le quotient intellectuel est évalué à
230, sa mère quand même !
Quand on sait qu'à partir
de 130, on est
considéré comme un surdoué.
Là, le gars, c'est un cerveau
avec deux petites jambes, comme ça, qui se promènent.
Quand il avait 2 ans,
ses parents l'ont vu en train d'apprendre
à compter à un enfant de 5 ans.
A 9 ans, il avait le niveau en math
pour entrer à l'Université.
Chill !
A 15 ans, il avait déjà écrit un livre
sur les méthodes
ses méthodes à lui
qu'il utilisait aux Olympiades
internationales de mathématiques,
pour lesquelles d'ailleurs, il a reçu
une médaille d'or à 13 ans.
Et à 20 ans,  il soutient une thèse
de mathématiques.
Et à 24 ans, Terence est enfin nommé professeur
à l'Université de Californie
de Los Angeles.
Ce qui en fait le plus jeune professeur
de l'histoire de cette école.
Vous imaginez si on avait pu calculer
son QI alors qu'il était encore bébé ?
Eh bien ça, c'est ce qui est pratiqué
depuis quelques dizaines
d'années maintenant.
Le club Mensa est une association
britannique pour lequel le droit d'entrée
c'est d'obtenir 140 ou plus à leurs tests de QI.
L'association compte 110.000 membres
à travers le monde, et notamment
des bébés.
Oui, des bébés, des petits bébés.
Adam Kirby 2 ans, 5 mois,
141 de QI. Il est entré en 2013 dans le club.
Alors, il savait épeler les mots,
il connaissait les tables de multiplication,
le nom de toutes les planètes.
Il apprenait le français,
comprenait le japonais et l'espagnol,
et il avait déjà lu du Shakespeare.
Entre deux biberons.
Anthony Popa Urria, 2 ans, 9 mois.
Il est rentré en 2019
avec un petit QI de 154.
Il avait encore des vêtements de bébé,
mais il savait déjà réciter l'alphabet.
Il comptait jusqu'à 1000
quand il avait le temps
et il avait d'ailleurs
la patience pour compter jusqu'à 1000.
Mais le record est détenu par Elise Tan Roberts.
A 5 mois,
elle prononçait ses premiers mots.
À 8 mois, elle faisait ses premiers pas.
À 16 mois, elle comptait jusqu'à 10.
À son entrée dans l'assoc,
en 2009, à l'âge de 2 ans et 4 mois,
elle savait donner et placer
35 capitales de pays.
Elle comptait en espagnol.
Elle savait faire la différence
entre un triangle isocèle
et un triangle équilatéral.
Elle avait clairement pas le time.
Est-ce que le fait que des bébés possèdent
aujourd'hui un QI incroyable voudrait dire
qu'on est tous plus intelligent qu'avant
ou en tout cas, plus tôt ? Et donc que l'ensemble
de la population est plus
intelligente qu'avant ?
Et bien non !
En fait, c'est tout l'inverse.
Les dernières études montrent que ça fait
15 ans qu'on est de plus en plus bêtes.
Ouais, c'est ce que je voulais dire.
En tout cas, selon ces études.
En 1987, James Flynn,
spécialiste néo-zélandais des recherches
sur l'intelligence,
a observé une augmentation des QI
moyen des populations au 20ème siècle.
Plutôt bon signe.
Ce même chercheur est l'un des premiers
à avoir tiré la sonnette d'alarme quand il vu, à l'inverse,
le renversement de cette tendance.
La petite chute qui commençait.
D'après une étude réalisée en 2013,
depuis 1995, le QI moyen de la population
a tendance à se casser la gueule.
Elle régresse.
Les Britanniques, par exemple,
ont perdu 14 points de QI.
C'est énorme par rapport
à la fin du 19e siècle.
Plus étonnant encore,
contrairement à ce qu'on pourrait croire
à l'époque des jeux vidéo et autres
stimulateurs de neurones,
les temps de réaction ont augmenté
et les Français sont pas mieux du tout.
On aurait perdu 3,8 points de QI
entre 1999 et 2009, soit en seulement
10 ans. D'après certaines personnes,
la consommation de drogues serait
l'un des facteurs de cette chute.
Pour d'autres, les coupables seraient
les perturbateurs endocriniens.
Pour d'autres encore, le problème,
c'est intéressant,
serait lié au fait que la sélection
naturelle n'a pas lieu chez les êtres
humains, qui gardent donc les gènes
des personnes peu ou pas intelligentes.
En fait, on se reproduit tous entre nous,
mais il n'y a plus la sélection naturelle,
où c'est ceux qui s'en sortent
le mieux qui se reproduisent.
Tout le monde a le droit.
Mais du coup, on est les seuls animaux
à pas avoir de sélection naturelle.
Se pose aussi la question de la fiabilité
de ce qu'on appelle le QI.
Mais ça, on y reviendra plus tard.
Du coup, est-il possible de booster son QI
pour remonter notre moyenne nationale?
En 1993, une étude essayait de démontrer
qu'écouter du Mozart permettait
d'augmenter son score de 8 à 9 points.
Les résultats sont ouf !
Mais ils n'ont jamais été
reproduits par la suite.
Donc, on a de quoi en douter.
Aujourd'hui,
il existe des applis d'entraînement cérébral,
mais il y a une étude de 2010
qui a été faite sur plus de 11.000 personnes
qui confirme que ces
applications ne permettent pas,
en réalité, d'améliorer
son intelligence générale.
Et si le secret, c'était tout
simplement dans l'éducation ?
D'après l'analyse de plusieurs études,
chaque année d'éducation supplémentaire
qu'on reçoit permettrait de gagner
1 à 5 points de quotient intellectuel.
C'est quand même beaucoup.
Le métier qu'on exerce
a peut être aussi un rôle à jouer,
car en 2014,
une étude montrait que les personnes
qui exercent un métier avec des tâches
complexes obtiennent de meilleurs
résultats aux tests de QI.
Mais si des bébés peuvent obtenir
des résultats supérieurs à 140,
est-ce que ce n'est pas un signe
que notre QI peut être inné ?
Des chercheurs de l'Université libre d'Amsterdam
ont identifié 40 nouveaux gènes
liés à l'intelligence qui jouent
notamment un rôle dans le
développement cérébral.
Bref, si vous voulez être plus
intelligent, la manière la plus simple
d'atteindre son objectif reste encore
de se cultiver et de rester curiouz.
J'ai dit curiouz.
Je voulais dire curieux, de rester curieux.
Mais tu me diras, c'est un lapsus qui tombe
bien pour vous dire que mon prochain
magazine Curiouz,
comporte un dossier qui sera consacré
au QI dans un numéro qui vous réserve
évidemment plein d'autres surprises.
Je vous en reparle en fin de vidéo.
Mais finalement, est ce qu'il faut
vraiment se fier à ces tests ?
Certains psychologues pointent du doigt
que l'erreur qui est faite par beaucoup
de parents, par exemple, avec le QI
de leurs enfants, c'est
de prendre le résultat
sans les explications
du professionnel qui vont avec.
Cette non-considération est notamment due
à la banalisation du test du QI.
Pour les professionnels du secteur,
il s'agit d'un outil et pas
d'un diagnostic final.
Un seul chiffre ne peut pas être
la réponse unique aux difficultés
que pourrait rencontrer
un enfant à un instant T.
Et puis, au final, le QI,
ça donne un résultat que sur un seul
faisceau de l'intelligence. Ça ne parle pas
de l'intelligence sociale, émotionnelle,
de la créativité, de plein d'autres choses.
Il n'existe pas qu'un seul test de QI.
Ils ne donneront en plus
pas tous le même résultat.
Donc, le QI,
c'est juste un point de départ
pour un psychologue, par exemple,
qui travaille sur un individu
et pas sur un chiffre.
Et après, il va confronter
ça à d'autres informations qui vont être
fournies par un examen psychologique
plus poussé, on va dire.
Et comme le dit le spécialiste en sciences
cognitives et directeur de recherche
au CNRS Frank Ramus, les scores de QI
sont calculés par rapport à une population
de référence qui donne une norme
statistique de l'intelligence
pour une tranche d'âge donnée
dans un pays donné à une période donnée.
On sait aujourd'hui que l'intelligence
est multidimensionnelle.
Et donc, que d'autres qualités mériteraient vraiment
d'être reconnues, comme je vous en parlais :
la créativité, l'intelligence sociale, etc. etc.
Si vous êtes abonné à mon magazine Curiouz,
vous le verrez
dans le numéro du mois prochain.
Un dossier très complet sur le QI
et, comme toujours, 52 pages fun
et curiouz dans tous les domaines.
Et si vous connaissez pas,
vous êtes libre de faire un tour sur le
site via le lien dans la description.
Pour lire des articles gratuitement,
voir aussi le contenu et les anciens numéros.
Anciens numéros que vous pouvez
enfin commander, à la demande,
depuis un an, c'est bon.
On sort même un livre collector
sur les 6 premiers numéros.
Vous verrez tout ça,
le lien est dans la description.
Petite précision néanmoins, l'abonnement
est d'un an pour 10 numéros, livrés
gratuitement dans le monde entier.
On ne pouvait pas faire plus simple.
Moi, je m'appelle toujours Fabien Olicard.
N'oubliez pas de vous abonner à cette
chaîne, d'activer la cloche,
de mettre un like sur cette vidéo
si elle vous a plu, évidemment.
Et ici, je vous mets ma deuxième chaîne,
la deuxième chaîne secondaire quoi.
Ici, une vidéo sur les 6 expériences stylées
faites sur le cerveau. Et ici une vidéo
sur 6 mystères non résolus à ce jour.
J'espère que le prochain numéro
de Curiouz vous plaira
autant que les précédents.
Prenez très soin de vous.
À très bientôt.
Tchao !